well the place where the miraculous is
is most evidence is in falling in love
falling in love is a really interesting
phenomenon I mean you you can be the guy
who marks the tires in the parking lot
of the great corporation and one day you
see the daughter of the first second and
fourth vice-president go by and you fall
in love with her and now watch what
happens mountains are moved coincidences
occur appointments cancelled deaths if
necessary in order to bring you together
and then you get married and are
unhappily spend the rest of your life
with this woman but in the in the
process of getting together almost
everybody experiences magic it's almost
as though the universal zeitgeist what
it's really interested in is gene
matching it's really interested in who
gets horizontal with who with
consequence because that's obviously how
it's steers and sculpts the historical
animal it understands that the pigments
of this oil painting are genes
and that the landscape is being painted
with the genetic in a genetic medium so
yeah it's very interesting